[Music]
in what does mine say news submitted by
North Korean History Channel here's what
your facial wrinkles say about your
lifestyle you know what mine says right
now my things are better subscribe or
you're gonna push in to face what pah
pah pah pah pah subscribe just in life
stuff I mean yeah where are my wrinkles
are my wrinkles here most of mine are
all my balls a lot here here here whoa
are your balls
most of my facial wrinkles are on my
balls oh can you tell me what my
wrinkles are so I want to know what my
life's tell all over that thing of bang
bang so I will go in order the first one
they have here is on one side if you
have wrinkles on one side it gives it a
way that you are a side sleeper
oh nice is you dry that actually does
[ __ ] that's what I'm asleep or at me to
one side that's what they're saying yet
dude my friend Jess only sleeps with her
back through the head to pillow cause
it's because of the [ __ ] I used to be as
I sleep when I'm a back sleeper somehow
Wow but then wouldn't her face be like
maybe that's why she stays young she
look so good you gotta get that uh what
do you call me hi I can't is like a herd
of waking a pregnancy or like what do
you call it the [ __ ] hemorrhoid chair
thing what oh thank the pillow yeah you
got to get the hemorrhoid chair thing
and put that at the back of your head
use that as a pillow oh not only mature
but it's for my head though yeah I can't
sleep on my back I wake up to on my side
and that [ __ ] my wrists always fall
asleep and then they heard my dog does
that
and I get so pissed cuz I'm like oh but
what's cutest type the sleeps like this
rollercoaster
[Applause]
upright on a chair so funny dude
sometimes I sleep like this with my
knees up like this no I do that with one
leg no weird yeah like this this is
pride while you're sitting I can just
one leg up just one right now I think
sitting down like um on flight systems
let's say you sleep good on flights then
probably oh I stink amazing oh I hate
flight sleeping before it even goes off
I can get that's my favorite I fall
asleep before we take off but then it's
on my dozer offer by the time I wake up
I'm always my tongue my tongue is like
swollen I gets a boner
I wake up with a really hard tongue I've
never seen you do that by the time I
wake up oh god my throat dry my tongue
swollen that's [ __ ] did I rather sleep
like that hey you should get a mouth
guard to put the mouth guard in and in
there's mouth tape for five oh my god
what do you put it on your lips we're
down in the ass you are you go like this
wait but I don't want to train my mouth
why did you use mouth tape because I
wanted to hear my MOT to stay close
because when I wake up my mouth is
really dry it's really dry isn't it
something with your nose then yeah cuz I
have I do it for sleep apnea Oh cuz the
breath huh maybe do you wear mouth tape
- yeah that's how I know about it and
then I I do double though cuz there's a
mouth guard for sleep apnea but then my
mouth will open up so I need the mouth
tape on top of it
I'll sleep like this right and then when
I turn over I take all the cooks all the
covers off of Nikki just rip them all we
got a king now and so it now when I do
it it doesn't take them all off I think
it's bigger yeah I roll over and tuck
and I sum and you like a big [ __ ]
baby how's she gonna pull that out like
next to him and then he's just like this
you see a freaky eyes all the way back
into her head I know you're caught me
moving on with the wrinkles if you are
if you have wrinkles on your cheeks or
it's saying that if you have dull and
dry cheeks it's a sign that you're not
drinking enough water
Oh doctor and dehydrated skin tends to
hold a light pinch instead of springing
back into place
well what about greasy ass came back to
the place I look like I bathe in oil
yeah cuz I don't have a greasy face I'm
gonna try face okay I'm a greasy food
yes spring springs right so you don't
know you're not dehydrated and my face
isn't dry rice greasy as [ __ ] yeah what
if it doesn't spring you just stays so
then you're dehydrated yeah you're
dehydrated that's what it means
yeah you drink zero water pinch up
period look know it's spring yes Springs
this brings back you think about me it
just stays it does I've been drinking
[ __ ] tons of water actually I'm doing a
sober October and I've been drinking
water like the moment good for you what
are you doing it's over October nobody
drinks no no alkies Wow it's one month
of flush you got that on Halloween party
Edmund was it October already you have a
Halloween party no well then I miss one
I was just trying to trap you know all
right if you have wrinkles in your mouth
it so if you have in your mouth if you
have these lines it means that you smile
a lot that's a good obviously
they're called laughter line that's
awesome obvious they're called Bulldog
lines the Bulldog is you look at Bulldog
you just made that up doesn't mean
everyone else all right if you have
lines or wrinkles in your lips is a tell
sign of your smoker oh I thought that
was a [ __ ] line yeah they could
really rip them up
that's a straw right there a ballbuster
no wrinkles in your lips show that
you're a smoker I guess that's what
they're saying I don't even know lips
had wrinkles they're saying that no
believe your eyes oh okay you do that
yeah I guess I would also say it's like
probably straws but they're saying here
that smoking creates free radical
formation that is bad for your skin
your skin cells collagen and the
lymphatic system which can cause skin to
look dull oh yeah so there's spiderweb
lines around the mouth
aka marionette lines they are usually
sign a sign that a person smokes
guys you haven't pays attention this
[ __ ] I came and focus on this [ __ ]
no that's a lot of people are getting
Botox like wrinkles yeah exactly
but like wrinkles hey say something
about your lifestyle Nikki knows a lot
about these things
oh for sure know that yeah the chicks
are mega mega into it so it's like oh
you live like this like you could look
at someone's face and you're like this
on the side or whatever I thought it was
gonna be like more like [ __ ]
horoscopes like if you have this wrinkle
let me do jack off too much or like
whatever it is sort of oh but maybe
that's what this one means you're shy or
some [ __ ] like that you know some things
are very mysterious you don't like to be
in crowds you smile a lot like you got a
rego on your nose a lot of Sun this side
is yeah this means you have a lot of
mystery yeah so eyes crow's feet on the
outer corner lives are often the first
wrinkles to appear Oh cuz you can't see
if you're wise but they're saying
that usually because of sun exposure
yeah so oh yeah
excessive UV rays or UV ray exposure
weakened skin cells and blood vessels
and this damage results in lines and
wrinkles as well as broken capillaries
and pigmentation crow's feet can deepen
into furrows if you're not using a daily
as SPF 30 cream don't you have crow's
feet yeah oh yeah we all talked about it
we talked about is crow's feet all right
you work those attempts I really I
really have those feet
yes Oh does that mean I could play older
and yeah rolls finally yet yes I didn't
know that crows had size 12 shoe
Wow if you have wrinkles in your brow am
I saying that it's problems because you
experience prolonged periods of stress
maybe it can resent me here ya know
these I just do that quick this is a
[ __ ] I'm just looking at your book
increases the production of the hormone
cortisol which degrades collagen leading
to my very happy right now his face is a
resting furrowed brow yeah the vertical
grooves going up to the forehead that's
what we're talking about do I have one
of those I know this no wait I mean I
looked at like a damn it Tom my mom has
one really deep right here really really
deep I remember noticing it when I was
really young so she was really young so
my damn she was really stressed so the
other ones is Ray Liotta face oh if you
look like really ugly yeah you probably
smoked every single second of every day
yeah his musics [ __ ] pretty crazy
it's like he's got like the acne scars
and life
got the whole gamut man yeah he looks
like Riverside
Riverside was a face yeah that's what it
looks like
that's you like forever farming and
browse okay so chin and forehead no big
fan radio we love we love right so
they're saying that when you're worried
too much it can lead to prominent
horizontal lines forming across your
forehead I worry a lot
you're a warrior dadless no that means I
never worry
no I feel like my forehead isn't big
enough if you do that yeah I think
everyone has it but they don't look like
wrinkles they just look like skin folds
that's cuz everyone has a forehead I
have a two head so I don't have enough
forehead to have a wrinkle on it
what is to hit I have a really small
smaller than you do I keep saying you do
you have everything [ __ ] average small
ears huh I'm really small is aerodynamic
put your ears next to the test pretty
much huh me oh my ears the same thing
yeah what there's one that's not no I
mean the synthesis Oh what could it be
good part yeah like one here's the other
you only want to kill her when she said
a bad species of [ __ ] that's what she
needs either mom she's the press let's
kick her down horrible it will help her
he'll talk you think now she's happy now
forget it she's boring alright and the
last one here is under eyes so they're
saying that dark circles can form if you
can confuse oome too much sugar
really oh that's what they're saying you
don't sleep enough for some so too much
sugar makes our adrenal glands work
harder which can lead to visible skin
issues when we consume sugar our bodies
go through glycation whereby toxic
compounds that damage elastin collagen
and even DNA are produced as some black
Asians right there
there must be a lot of sugar I love but
we eat it just time Ashok is amazing
it's in everything it's in everything oh
yeah I'm like sugar but it's an alcohol
and so I'm like dude if I'm gonna lose
these last like 15 pounds I got to be
done with this [ __ ] forever you're
awesome you're on it man
yeah I care I care now
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]